beyonce's renaissance is here and she's
addressing those early album
weeks while i
[Music]
the queen turned the sexy dial to level
100 for her seventh studio album and
it's full of sultry songs and dance
bangers it feels good to know that the
hard work paid off and that hard work is
reflected on the 16 track lp which
includes the hit lead single break my
soul
but uh back to that whole sexy vibe
bee's track thick yes spelled with a q
has us over here sweating
[Music]
[Music]
hit it in the car and take you back to
the casa anyone else getting partitioned
deja vu
[Music]
but the song getting lots of love from
fans online alien superstar a strings
heavy track that be co-wrote with her
hubby
[Music]
jay-z baby
[Music]
there's no doubt the beehive was
counting down the minutes to
renaissance's release including her mama
i'm very very excited you know i i just
posted recently that i really miss her
singing and i do
um
so i'm just i'm as excited as everybody
else i can't wait for you guys to hear
it she put two years of love into this
many many nights all night working and
so i can't wait for the for the world to
hear it and when e.t chatted with queen
b's bestie and former destiny's child
bandmate kelly roland she kept a coy and
did what she does best sing i know
you've heard beyonce's album how is it
hi i don't know what you're talking
about how's that out oh come on
come on now you won't break myself but
as luck would have it b had to deal with
an early album leak ahead of its release
tracks started popping up online leaving
the protective beehive buzzing alright
so when the album finally dropped at
midnight b expressed her gratitude with
a handwritten note she posted on
instagram thanking her fans for their
love and protection i appreciate you for
calling out anyone that was trying to
sneak into the club early it means the
world to me thank you for your
unwavering support thank you for being
patient we're going to take out time and
enjoy the music
[Music]